[Music]  okay i don't think that was a man on  second thought i'm not i can't be too  sure  as far as the idea that men shouldn't  chime in on abortion i i mean  just shut up shut the [ __ ] up  let's run through the problems with that  claim one more time number one you can't  do that anymore you believe that that  there are no differences between between  the male and female bodies  that it's fluid you believe that you  could be a have a male body and still be  a woman and that you're just as much a  woman as any other one so you can't play  this card anymore that's been taken from  you it's gone it's not in the deck  anymore you can't play it also men  decided roe v wade so if we're going to  get rid of male opinions on abortion  that means we're getting rid of roe v  wade men also are 50 of the ingredients  needed to create an unborn child which  you would all which you would also think  would give us a stake in the question